c
oui en plein dans
m000 Oh
w
Bel
k
Ha
déjà
Oh
pour les hommes et les
les femmes la
art violent
violence
Non la violence stop la violence arr la
violence viol arrête la violence arr la
violence stop elle fait trop de mort
trop de mal trop de trop de meurtrier
mon cur se mon app pleure la violence
provoquer trop de malheur diviser les frr
et diviser les SS c'est par les cou TR de
femmes qui meurent détruites des pays o
ils ont provoqué des guerres sur les routes
trop d'innocence dans les cimetières mon
cur mon app pleur mon app pleur
ouais la violence stop la violence arr
la violence stop elle fait trop de mort
trop de mal trop de trop de meurtrier
Arrêtez la violence Arrêtez la violence
violence stop elle fait
TR